- This episode of LegalEagle
(gentle music)
was made possible by Skillshare.
Learn to think like a lawyer
for free for two months
by clicking on the link
in the description.
Recent events have raised the question
of whether a sitting
president can be indicted
while in office or whether
the president is immune
from criminal prosecution.
It has never happened before.
The text of the Constitution is unclear
and there are good
arguments on both sides.
Welcome to Lawsplainer, a
new series on LegalEagle
where I try to tackle some
of the core legal concepts
that form the foundation of our society
because sometimes the law is complicated
and needs to be 'splained.
(gavel thuds)
Today we are talking about
whether a sitting president
can be criminally indicted.
This is a legal concept
that becomes relevant
every 20 years of so starting
with President Nixon,
moving on to President Clinton,
and now potentially President Trump.
But first let's talk about the difference
between indictment and impeachment.
Indictment is a criminal
accusation against an individual.
It is essentially the way you
start a criminal prosecution.
So for example, if someone
murdered another person,
the state would indict
that person for murder.
However impeachment is a
purely political mechanism
used to remove and official
from the federal government.
It is a formal charge of wrongdoing
and potentially removing them from office.
But unlike an indictment, it
does not necessarily result
in jail time.
In popular parlance,
impeachment generally refers
to the president but it can
actually refer to a wide variety
of federal government employees.
In fact, most of the impeachments
that have actually occurred
involve Supreme Court justices
not just the President
of the United States.
So you might ask, why would anyone think
that the president is
immune from prosecution?
Well, first let's recognize
that most government officials
are immune from suit
in order to allow them
to focus on their jobs
as elected officials.
For example, the doctrine
of qualified immunity
protects officials from
facing criminal charges
or lawsuits for their actions
as long as their actions
are within the course
and scope of their jobs.
Qualified immunity is often
a defense that gets raised
in suits against police
officers or police departments.
Additionally, looking at the
text of the Constitution,
you'll notice that it
does mention impeachment
of the president, but it
does not mention indictment.
However, the absence of that statement
does not necessarily mean
that it's not available.
So there's ambiguity in the Constitution.
Which is why the Office of Legal Counsel
has dealt with this topic on
a few different occasions.
The Office of Legal Counsel, or OLC,
is part of the United
States Justice Department
that acts as a legal
advisor to the president
and the executive branch
when they have questions
about the legality of a
particular action or law.
Generally it's seen as
a non-partisan office.
When the president has a question of law,
he or she turns to the OLC
to give an objective opinion.
Relevant here, the OLC
has written three memos
on the question of whether the president
can be criminally indicted.
The first OLC memo was issued in 1973
shortly before the Saturday Night Massacre
in which Nixon fired
Watergate Special Prosecutor
Archibald Cox and the
top two Justice officials
resigned in protest.
That memo considers
the Constitution's text
and finds no answer.
It finds that the Constitution provides
very limited immunities
for members of Congress
and none for the president.
With no clear constitutional answer,
the OLC lawyers asked what answer
would best serve the nation?
They found that an indictment
in office would besmirch
the quote symbolic head of the nation
and given that impeachment
is the only tool mentioned
in the Constitution, the memo finds
that this would suggest strongly
that criminal proceedings
against a president in
office should not go beyond
the point that would
effectively remove the president
and thus become a shortcut to impeachment.
A second memo written
just a few days later
by Robert Bork argues
that the same points apply
to the vice president as well.
Of course, those memos were never tested
as President Nixon resigned
before either impeachment
or indictment and was
pardoned by President Ford.
27 years later in the year 2000,
the OLC reexamined the question.
By this time there had been
major Supreme Court decisions,
which we'll talk about in a second,
all indicating that the
president was, in fact,
not immune to the reach
of the justice system.
But the OLC found that despite case law,
the president was still immune
from criminal prosecution.
The OLC memo from the year 2000 states
that quote, the framers
considered who should possess
the extraordinary power of deciding
whether to initiate proceeding
that could remove the president
and placed that responsibility
in the elected officials of Congress.
It would be inconsistent
with that carefully considered judgment
to permit an unelected
grand jury and prosecutor
to effectively remove a president
by bringing criminal charges against him
while he remains in office.
So again the OLC concluded
that a sitting president
could not be criminally indicted.
However, unbeknownst to the public,
two years earlier in 1998, a secret memo
written for Independent
Counsel Kenneth Starr
reached the opposite conclusion.
At the height of the Starr investigation
and the Lewinsky scandal,
Independent Counsel Kenneth Starr
commissioned a legal memo
seeking guidance on this question
as to whether a sitting
president can be indicted.
Mr. Starr assigned Ronald Rotunda,
a prominent Conservative professor
of constitutional law to write this memo
as a consultant.
The memo has only recently been revealed
after a FOIA request
by The New York Times.
The Starr memo argues that
President Clinton at the time
could be indicted because
quote, the US Supreme Court
has repeatedly reaffirmed the statement
that no one is above the law.
The memo argued that the
Independent Counsel's statue itself
made no sense if the
Counsel could not, in fact,
indict the president.
And President Clinton
had consented to passage
of the statute that created the office.
So, in effect, he had
consented to being indicted.
The Starr memo argued that it is quote,
proper and constitutional and
legal for a federal grand jury
to indict a sitting president
for serious criminal acts
that are not part of and are contrary to
the president's official duties.
The Starr office memo concludes by saying
that in this country, no
one, even President Clinton,
is above the law.
So in terms of executive branch memoranda,
there have been three memoranda that say
that the president cannot
be criminally indicted,
at least not while in office
and one that says the
president can, in fact,
be indicted while
sitting as the president.
But you should probably consider the bias
of these particular sources.
The three no-indictment
opinions were issued
by executive branch lawyers who, in fact,
work for the president.
And the one legal memorandum that argues
that the president can be
indicted came specifically
at the request of the famously,
perhaps infamously, zealous Kenneth Starr.
Of course, it has been noted
that the Department of Justice
has an active policy of not
indicting a sitting president.
However, this is a policy preference
of the Department of
Justice and no one argues
that it is mandated by the
Constitution or statute.
It may or may not be a good
idea but there is no law
that requires this particular DOJ policy.
And this DOJ policy and those memos
from the Office of Legal
Counsel may be well-reasoned
but none of them are binding.
The final answer may
come to us specifically
from the Supreme Court
of the United States.
And if we're talking
about the Supreme Court,
we should look at past
Supreme Court precedent.
There are two Supreme Court
cases that are on point.
The first is US versus Nixon.
In that case, Nixon argued
that he need not turn over
what became the famous Nixon tapes,
the smoking gun of the
whole Watergate affair.
In US versus Nixon, the
Supreme Court confirmed
that the president is
susceptible to discovery
that might result in criminal
charges against the executive.
The Supreme Court rejected
President Nixon's claim
to a quote, absolute, unqualified
presidential privilege
of immunity from judicial
process under all circumstances.
US versus Nixon required
that the president
turn over his tapes to a
court seeking to use them
in a criminal case
against other defendants.
This was a unanimous decision of 8-0
with Justice Rehnquist recusing himself
because of his close ties
to the Nixon administration.
The next relevant Supreme Court case
came about 20 years later
in Clinton versus Jones.
In 1994, Paula Jones filed a
civil sexual harassment suit
against President Clinton.
Although the allegations
related to Clinton's conduct
as Governor of Arkansas,
Jones filed her suit
about five months after Clinton
took office as president.
Although Clinton, like Nixon,
claimed absolute immunity
from legal process while in office,
the Court again rejected that claim.
The Supreme Court held unanimously
that President Bill Clinton could be sued
in civil court over the sexual advances
he allegedly made while
being Governor of Arkansas.
Clinton's lawyers, like
Nixon's before him,
argue that the president's
participation in a trial
would imperil the executive branch
because it would distract
him from all the complex
and numerous responsibilities
of being president.
But the Court decided that this principle
was outweighed by the
requirement that litigants
be able to seek justice
when they are wronged.
Although Clinton v Jones
involved a civil case
and not a criminal case,
there's probably no reason
why the Court's logic can't
extend to criminal cases.
Indeed you could argue that
the interest of justice
would be even more
important in a criminal case
as opposed to a civil case for damages.
Like many issues in
constitutional jurisprudence,
there are no easy answers
to this particular question.
And when lawyers don't
have binding precedent,
they make what are
called policy arguments.
In other words, in cases
of first impression,
they argue what would make the best law?
So let's look at a few of
those arguments on both sides.
Those arguing for immunity from indictment
would claim that the president
is singularly important.
They would argue that the
president can't be distracted
by civil and criminal
suits that would prevent
the president from turning
his or her attention
to actually running the country.
And, in fact, this was the basis
of Justice Kavanaugh's Law Review piece
that became relevant during
his confirmation hearings.
Kavanaugh argued that
because the president
is so important, Congress
should pass a law
that makes the president
exempt from investigations,
exactly the kind of
investigations that Kavanaugh
helped run during the Starr investigation.
However, Kavanaugh doesn't
argue that this is mandated
by the Constitution, simply
that Congress should, in fact,
pass that law.
Proponents of immunity would
also argue logistical problems.
The president is the
head of the Executive.
So how can the president
effectively oversee
his or her own trial and investigation
and potential criminal conviction?
They would also argue
that we already have
a remedy, impeachment.
If the president has done
some sort of wrongdoing,
it's up to Congress in order
to reprimand the president
and remove them from office.
And once they are removed from office,
then prosecute any crimes
that may or may not have occurred.
But I think even those that
would argue for immunity,
would agree that if indeed
the president is immune
from criminal prosecution of events
that occurred before
they became president,
that the statute of limitations
must be tolled while they're in office
otherwise becoming
president literally would be
a get-out-of-jail-free card.
On the other hand, those who would argue
against presidential immunity
and those who would argue
that, in fact, a
president can be indicted,
would point out that pre-election conduct
is by definition not related
to their job as president.
No official should be above the law.
It's a principle that is
reaffirmed time and time again
from the Supreme Court.
And to borrow an example
that President Trump uses
from time to time--
- I have the most loyal people.
Did you ever see that?
Where I could stand in
the middle of 5th Avenue
and shoot somebody and I
wouldn't lose any voters, okay?
(audience laughing)
It's like incredible.
- If he shot a man in
cold blood on 5th Avenue,
perhaps his followers might not care,
but I think as a society
we would probably want
the president prosecuted for that crime.
This issue is sort of
like the Schrodinger's cat of politics.
As with many things in the law,
we may not have an answer
until the actual action
in question is taken and the
Supreme Court issues a decision
that finally tells us
one way or the other.
Until then, in the absence
of a law passed by Congress
or a constitutional amendment,
we may never know the
answer to this question.
But if we do ever have a sitting president
that is indicted and criminally convicted,
they can make good use of their jail time
by taking a course on Skillshare.
Just spitballing here but they could take
Matt Cooper's class on
accounting fundamentals
so they don't have any issues
with their tax returns.
Or they could take Guy Kowasaki's class
on turning ideas into
high growth businesses
so they can learn how to
run a profitable business
that never has to file for bankruptcy.
Skillshare is an online learning community
that has over 20,000 classes on everything
like business, design, and technology.
The first 500 LegalEagles
to click the link below will get
two free months of Skillshare.
The free premium membership
gives you unlimited access
to must-know topics so you
can improve your skills
and learn new things.
Learn something useful not politics.
Click the link and get two free months
and start learning today.
And until next time,
I'll see you in court.